welcome back well happy hour just got a
little happier because the vegas pets
kitchen has just launched their menu and
today we are getting a taste of it so
joining us is vegas test kitchen founder
jolene monina and the black pearl chef
daniel arias thank you guys so much for
being here thanks for having us so let's
talk about the vegas test kitchen i
think it's such a cool concept but for
people who aren't familiar what exactly
is it so we're a multi-concept
restaurant we open during the pandemic
um we have seven chefs that are tenants
there so when you come in you have the
um access to eat with several different
chefs that's such a cool idea and a
great way to just get a taste of all
different things and you guys are
launching a happy hour
what does that entail yeah we wanted to
highlight a different spirit each week
so every thursday at the test kitchen
from five to eight you can come in we'll
have specialty cocktails very good price
we're also offering a snack menu so five
of our chefs that are part of the test
kitchen will be there offering little
bites yeah so chef daniel let's talk
about what you're making over here and
what people can expect to you know get a
taste of from you
so for happy hour we're going to have
some us
special cones so it's a tuna ceviche
as well we have a little bit of a
our chilis so a little traditional and
as well our famous style pretty much a
beer batter shrimp tacos oh it looks so
good and i have to say i love the
presentation you have actual seashells
on here did you have to go to california
together
them
that's so cool you brought the beach to
us here in vegas so let's talk about
what's in the ceviche here and i love
the cone display that's just a fun
element so yeah so
the cones actually they're custom made
for us
it's a new concept that we can bring to
vegas
and we're trying to do is like a
fast-paced uh ceviche it's on the go i
love it so this is a new thing we're
coming up so
you can only try it at the vegas test
kitchen
so
and i have to ask you just take a bite
like an actual ice cream cone out of it
or how do you recommend eating it with
avocado under it and then you have the
ceviche top i know you might want to
help us with this one so
i don't know if you should trust me you
should see me in the kitchen
do it it's pretty easy and just really
quickly too as you're wrapping this up i
don't want to forget because happy hour
isn't complete without the drink so what
are some of the drives
this week we're um we're working with
frey ranch frey ranch is local to nevada
um so we'll have like one specialty
console with them and then offer a
variety of mixers with frey ranch so the
first 20 people that actually come to
happy hour will get a free cocktail on
us
right show up early leave late well it's
going to be a party at the vegas test
kitchen and can people just pop in or do
they need reservations they can walk in
totally fine and where are you guys
located we are located on fremont east
so 10 20 fremont east right right next
to uh ferguson's downtown awesome well
thank you guys so much uh this is
beautiful can't wait to come in and try
it
be sure to check out the new javier
vegas test kitchen mercedes i'll send it
over to you
thanks